go for coco conan there's a man here
from tbs to conduct your exit interview
ah send them in hello my name is homer
simpson and i'm looking for a big star
in tbs
that would be me oh my god you're one of
the impractical jokers
uh no actually i that time you and sal
blew up that toilet
i can't believe that guy lived
homer homer i mean he was in a
wheelchair
i'm a talk show host wow a dying breed
there's only like
800 of you left homer you work in hr i
thought you worked at a nuclear power
plant well over the years i've had
hundreds of jobs
at one point i was even a monorail
conductor
what a stupid idea that was actually
seems like kind of a
nifty idea to me no
it's a terrible idea let's do the exit
interview huh
all right sure nerd so uh how long have
you been working at tibbs
i think you mean tbs uh thanks for the
help smart guy but i think i know how to
spell
tibs uh it says here you're on your
third late-night show
that is correct are you uh proud of the
work you did on this show
the third one i mean yes homer i am
everyone seems to have their favorite
moments uh
hey what was yours oh you know what come
to think of it i do remember one
there was a time you had this actor on
and he was promoting a movie
and you asked him if there was any wacky
stuff that happened on the set
so he told this mildly interesting
anecdote
okay well holmes director fell asleep
halfway through okay homer you just
described pretty much all the shows i've
ever done
good thing i only saw one then how would
your co-workers describe you
i could say i'm fair honest and
endlessly creative
you're supposed to use one word or less
irish
all right i rare
yeah it's funny you don't look irish
you're the first one to say that to me
red hair big fat face freckles you know
what i better get a pencil and write all
this down uh anything else you'd like to
add
yes there is homer there's something i
want you to see i've never shown anyone
before
take a look oh my god
you're beautiful thank you homer you
mean the world to me
you mean the world to me conrad it's
conan
conan that's not a real name
that meant the world to me that they
went to all that trouble
uh i know that the simpsons is a show
that hasn't ever broken through
uh if but i want to give him a little
leg up so
check this show out it's on sundays on
fox
okay the family
you